we're going to do in this video is look
at the work of other people as they try
to take derivatives and see if their
reasoning is correct and if it's not
correct try to identify what they should
have done or where their reasoning went
wrong so over here it says Nate tried to
find the derivative of x squared plus 5x
times sine of X here is his work is
Nate's work correct if not what's his
mistake so pause the video and see if
you can answer this
his Nate's work correct and if not what
his mistake all right so I'm assuming
you've had a go at it
so let's work through this step by step
so over here he's just trying to apply
the derivative operator to the
expression which is exactly what he
needed to do he's trying to find the
derivative of this thing and he says ok
this is a product of two expressions and
then he says okay well this is going to
be the same thing as the derivative or
this is the same thing as the product of
the derivatives now this is a problem
you are probably familiar if I take the
derivative of the sum of two things so
the derivative with respect to X of f of
X plus G of X that indeed is equal to
the derivative of the first F prime of X
plus the derivative of the second but
that is not true if we are dealing with
the product of functions the derivative
with respect to X of f of X G of X is
not necessarily maybe there's some very
special circumstances but in general
it's not going to be just the product of
the derivative it's not going to be just
F prime of X G prime of X here we would
want to apply the product rule this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to the derivative of the first
function times the second function plus
the derivative well let me write it this
way plus the first function not taking a
straight if time's the derivative of the
second function so he should have
applied the product rule here and so
let's do that just to see what his
answer should have been so what he
should have done here I'll get my
correcting red pen out
here say no that's not what he should
have done he says let's take the
derivative of this first thing so
actually let me do the color coded so
the derivative of this is 2x plus 5 so
it should have been 2x plus 5 times the
second thing so times sine of x times do
it in another color times sine of X and
then to that he would add the first
thing which is x squared plus 5x times
the derivative of the second thing so
the derivative of sine of X is cosine of
X so this is what he should what we
should have been seeing at this step
right over here he shouldn't have just
taken the product of the derivatives he
should have applied the product rule so
his work is not correct and his mistake
is that he didn't apply the product rule
he just took he just assumed that the
derivative of the products is the same
thing as the product of the derivatives
there's two more examples okay so let's
see it says Katie tried to find the
derivative of 2x squared minus 4 all of
that to the third power
here is her work is Katie's work correct
if not what is her mistake so once again
pause the video see if you can figure it
out
alright now let's inspect Katie's work
so she's taking the derivative of this
and let's see over here it looks like
she's taking the derivative of the
entire expression with respect to the
inner expression and that is close to
applying the chain rule properly but
it's not applying the chain rule
properly so her work is not correct and
our mistake is she's not correctly
applying the chain rule just as a review
the chain rule says look if we're trying
to take the derivative with respect to X
of of F of G of X F of G of X that this
is going to be equal to this is going to
be equal to the derivative of the whole
thing with respect to G of X so I could
write that as f prime of
G of X F prime of G of X times the
derivative of the inner function with
respect to X times G prime of X so over
here then we could view our F function
it's the thing that takes its input and
takes it to the third power and so this
right over here is f prime of G of X so
this thing is the F prime of G of X but
she forgot to multiply it by the
derivative of the inner function with
respect to X so she forgot to multiply
this times the derivative of 2x squared
minus 4 with respect to X which is going
to be let's see the derivative of 2x
squared power rule 2 times 2 is 4 so
it's going to be 4 X to the first and
then the derivative of negative 4 is
just a 0 so it's going to be times 4x so
that's what she needed to do in order
for it to be correct so she had to have
this x for X here times 4x so not
correct
she didn't up correctly apply the chain
rule so let's do another one of these
so here says the Jomon tried to find the
derivative of sine of 7x squared plus 4x
here's his work is no Joe mons work
correct if not what is his mistake pause
the video see if you can figure it out
all right so it's the derivative of sine
of this expression so you'd want to use
the chain rule and find using the chain
rule you want to find the derivative of
the outside function with respect to the
inside so the derivative of sine of
something with respect to that something
is going to be cosine of that something
so that's right that's right and then
you want to multiply that times the
derivative of the inside with respect to
X so the derivative 7x squared is 14x
derivative of 4x is 4 so this is
actually that step looks good but then
the Jomon does something strange over
here this is the cosine of 7x squared
plus 4x and then that whole thing times
14 X plus 4 but they get confused we're
just looking at these parentheses and
this tends to happen sometimes it's
actually one of these key errors that
the folks at the College Board ap folks
about that when dealing with these
transcendental functions cosine sin to
sine tangent natural log that are
written like this and people see the
parentheses and see in other parentheses
their brain this is oh let me multiply
these two parentheses two expressions in
parentheses but that's not right because
if we were to add parentheses this is
what this is implying so you can't just
take the 14 X + 4 and multiply it by
this and assuming you're taking the
cosine of the whole thing so this is
where the Jomon makes the mistake the
work is not correct and the mistake is
trying to multiply these two expressions
and taking the cosine of the whole thing
let's do one more of these I find these
strangely fun all right this one is
involved Tom tried to find the
derivative of the square root of x over
X to the fourth here is his work is
Tom's work correct if not what's his
mistake pause the video and see if you
can figure that out so it looks like
he's trying to apply the quotient rule
so applying the quotient rule you would
in the numerator you would take the
derivative of the first expression times
the second expression and then minus the
first expression times the derivative of
the second expression all of that over
the or I should say the derivative the
first the numerator expression over the
times the denominator expression minus
the numerator expression times the
derivative of the denominator expression
all of that over the denominator
expression squared so this looks correct
actually it's correct application of the
quotient rule
it looks like tom is correctly
simplifying so the derivative of X to
the 1/2 is 1/2 X to the negative 1/2 so
that looks right derivative of X to the
fourth is 4x to the third so that looks
right all of this looks algebraically
right and let's see when you simplify
this so it's the X to the negative 1/2
times X to the fourth is indeed x2 well
that's going to be X to the OH
this correlates so this simplifies to
that which looks correct and that
simplifies to that which looks correct
we're just using exponent properties
there and then divided everything by
let's see oh then everything in terms of
X - 3.5 so
so we're going to have negative negative
3.5 x to 3.5 and then you use exponent
property so it actually looks like he
did everything correctly this is the
right answer now so his work is correct
he did not make any mistakes
but I would I do have a bone to pick so
speak with Tom because he didn't have to
apply the quotient rule here he did all
of this Harry calculus and algebra but
there could have been a very simple
simplification he could have made up
here and this is a key thing to realize
he could have said hey you know what
this is the same thing it's a derivative
with respect to X of of X to the
one-half that's what the square root of
x is times X to the negative fourth
power that's what the X that's what 1
over X to the fourth is and so let me
color code it so that is the same thing
as that and that is the same thing as
that and you wouldn't even have to use a
product rule here you could simplify
this even further this is the same thing
as the derivative with respect to X of
this we have the same base we can add
the exponents working the products it's
going to be X to the negative 3 point X
to the negative 3.5 and so you can just
use the power rule so this is going to
be equal to bring the negative 3.5 out
front negative 3.5 x to the and then we
just decrement this one by one we
subtract one from that negative 4.5
power so as you can see he could have
gotten this answer much much much much
much much quicker but he didn't make any
mistakes there's a little bit of a
judgment error just immediately to going
forth with the quotient rule which gets
quite hairy quite fast